this this event is sponsored by Public
Square if you guys want to help win the
culture war and support businesses that
support our values download the Public
Square app check out businesses in your
area I really do mean it all right so
could you tell us a little bit about
Public Square just for those who might
not be familiar with it happy to uh so
we are the largest Network in the world
of businesses that do not hate you
they're not going to lecture you about
gender or politics or Ukraine when
you're simply trying to buy a pair of
pants and it's very refreshing so uh we
started the company I had the idea in
January of 2021 we were in the heart of
the co season I was from San Diego
California and all of a sudden the
decade of tyranny that was building in
the world of corporate America came to a
boiling point when all of a sudden
businesses started asking me my mask or
vaccine status when you'd try to just go
and enter and get a cup of coffee and we
had had enough I wasn't cool with that
level of tyranny it felt like like
businesses were operating more as
political organizations rather than
providers of value and service there was
a time in this country when the customer
was always right and it felt like now I
was subjected to the whims of a business
that was acting more like a government
organization than a provider of value so
my wife and I wrote down on a piece of
paper a list of 20 businesses in San
Diego County where we knew the owner we
knew the values of the owner we knew
that they stood with us our freedoms our
liberties and our values therefore we
could support them
went to dinner one night at one of these
businesses and felt like gosh what if we
actually put this list in a digital
environment and what if businesses could
add themselves to the list and what if
other consumers could join and access
the list and the business list could
actually be compilated in alignment with
these values we could really create an
economy that would serve the values of
we the people in a really transformative
fashion launched that in San Diego 9
months later and then as of July 4th of
2022 so about 15 months ago we launched
it to the entire nation since then we've
hit a million members on the platform
faster than Twitter Airbnb Spotify the
thing has grown tremendously largely
because we the people people like you
people like me are tired we're tired of
feeling like our rights are trampled and
[Applause]
violated and the dream was what if we
were not just forced and left to boycott
but what if we could actually take the
next step and put our money behind the
businesses we know we can believe in
because they love the country the
Constitution and the values that it
protects and in the process we would
actually be able to shift the power
structures of society back toward we the
people through the marketplace so
there's Public Square and all through a
conversation with your wife it's a
reason to get married I love that oh
yeah marriage is the best highly
recommend awesome so you added some new
features to Public Square recently right
we have and actually uh adding more soon
so when we started the platform it was a
directory uh
actually August 9th of 2022 I went on
timcast and had an amazing time showing
the platform we were only live for a
month at that point and Tim was kind
enough he saw the vision he wanted to
come on he wanted to talk about it and
so I joined him and showed the features
and back then it was very primitive and
archaic and yet the amount of people
that joined us and built the plane in
Flight with us was tremendous now a year
later you know I was on with him last
night talking about some of the
announcements that we have coming up in
the coming weeks November one actually
we're moving the platform from a
directory where you find businesses and
products but you actually have to
purchase on their site we're moving from
that to a fully immersive e-commerce
marketplace where you can actually have
multiple vendors one shopping cart check
out at the point of sale we've written
all that code from scratch I've built
our own shopping cart experience and uh
I'll say this between that between a
whole new search functionality between
right now when you go to the platform
public sq.com you have to have an
account you log in you sign up that was
purposeful in the early days so we could
kind of court early adopters but now
November 1 we're dropping that account
wall so you can just browse without ever
having to sign in or log in really
exciting we're making all yeah thank you
thank you we're making all these changes
so that we can truly compete against the
Commerce giants like Amazon Walmart
Target that have become corrupted
institutions that are destroying our
country small businesses of this nation
have been put on the back burner while
the greatest wealth transfer in history
happened in 2020 and 21 between the
small businesses to Amazon no wonder
Jeff Bezos love lockdowns he was
profiting from it and so our goal coming
out of that season is provide a platform
that has the features of an Amazon but
supports the small businesses that have
made our country special if we can do
that we're going to win in the long run
so check out November 1 it's going to be
really exciting awesome I'm excited
about
this
so so Michael you like myself fled
communism in a state yes yeah we are
political refugees yes anybody in the
audience a political Refugee hell yeah
hell yeah all right cool so so you're a
very values driven person do you think
that that had something to do with
Public Square a th% yeah I um what's
interesting is there was a poll done by
5w consumer research in 2020 that found
that 83% of Millennials actively fact in
the values a company espouses before
they shop there companies today are
wearing their values on their sleeve and
so when you're shopping with Amazon
you're forced to support now all the
stuff that Amazon supports when you shop
with Starbucks you're forced to support
all the things that they support and for
me given that I'm a very values driven
person I hold my convictions near and
dear my family does uh we were really
tired of feeling like those are our only
options when Target does what it does
and wants to lecture your kids about
sexuality and gender when you're just
trying to go by a pair of pants or
swimsuits like the country's lost the
plot we are way too far gone so for me
it felt like I was empowering people
that actively hated me in my family's
values by continuing to fund their
economic engine what's beautiful about
Public Square is that a lot of the
businesses on the platform they have
conservative values or America First
values they're Constitution Le but they
don't they're not political They Don't
lecture you about your political views
most of the businesses you shop from on
the platform you wouldn't even know that
they have any political standing other
than the fact that they've been aligned
with Public Square and they've joined us
on the journey so that's kind of the
future I want I want an economy I think
we all do where the businesses that have
made our communities really special can
prosper and we don't feel like we have
to sacrifice our convictions in order to
get a freaking cup of coffee and uh yeah
values obviously led us to move the
company from California to Florida so
we're an hour and a half north in West
Palm Beach we love Florida
yeah so I want to ask you about your
vision for the future with Public Square
last time you were on timcast IRL you
said something I find really interesting
you had all these people calling in to
say hey you should try this you should
maybe get this idea and you said these
are all great I love it but we want to
nail it before we scale it and I was
just wondering what does that look like
going forward obviously you're directly
challenging Amazon with this shopping
cart change what's
next uh well we announced on timcast
last night we're going to launch a
Public Square Shark Tank series so we're
really stoked about that so right now
there's two things happening in the
country one is that if you're an
investor and you have access to Capital
uh you know we complain about the George
Soros of the world as we should the guy
is like run by demons he's awful right
the the dude hates us and our families
George sorus is not a good dude neither
is his son and uh a lot of these people
are putting money toward the causes they
believe in and if you look at Wall
Street today it's largely run by ESG and
Dei dominated Enterprises that have
completely left behind behind
shareholder value so you've got
investors that are tired of that they
want to actually invest in companies
that believe in the future of the
country that they want to create that
are prioritizing meritocracy and
Excellence that aren't hiring because of
diversity quotas they're hiring for the
best
candidates that's what investors are
looking for then on the other side of
things you have a group of businesses
that are starving for Capital because if
you're a small business in the United
States today or a startup with values
like ours sooa capital is not calling
you
if you're a small business that would
generally rely on private Equity to grow
are youall familiar with Blackstone you
ever heard of
Blackstone so there's Black Rock black
rock is on the public equities Asset
Management side and then you have black
stone black stone is private Equity so
what they'll do is they'll take a
beautiful mom and pop family-owned and
operated small business from your
hometown and they'll say you know what
I'll price you at one and a half times
sales which screws small businesses it
basically provides no value it all all
it says is hey I'll buy you or take a
controlling stake in the company
basically for the same amount of money
that you'll make this year on your own
but you need capital I have Capital so
now you're subjected to me they'll take
over the business they'll corrupt the
values and all of a sudden you have an
agent of the largest private Equity
Group in the world that has adopted ESG
standards so if you're a small business
and you want Capital but you don't want
to be taken advantage of you need to
partner with values aligned investors so
one thing we're doing is working hard at
connecting those two entities we're
trying to connect the small businesses
that need access to Capital and we're
trying to connect the investors that
aren't going to try to indoctrinate the
small business owners and instead we'll
celebrate the values that made them so
special in the first place so that's
happening that's really exciting we're
also focusing well thank you very
exciting we're also um focusing really
heavily on making sure that um no matter
what you're looking for throughout your
day-to-day life you can find it on
Public Square so I was actually informed
Yesterday by our team that we have like
three toilet paper companies now so even
if you're looking for toilet paper you
can find it on Public Square what's
interesting is that we've found some
holes in the market we've found some
areas in which there are not values
aligned alternatives for certain
industry Niche so what we're doing is
where we find holes in the market we'll
actually go and create products that
meet those needs and sell them back into
the marketplace so for example every
single major diaper brand in the United
States every single baby brand I have an
11 month old any of you have babies yeah
few of you love it so uh we found out
last summer that every single major
diaper brand in the United States today
is uh either vocally or financially
supporting abortion now I know there's a
lot of people that have varying views on
that issue in this room yeah by the way
it makes zero does seem counterintuitive
to their business model I will say yeah
yeah it would be like me saying I want
to start a men shoe company and I'm
going to use some of the profits to cut
yeah exactly cut off part of the Dei and
the Dei standards saying have to support
abortion yeah it's to get a high ESG
score what's fascinating though is that
when you're diaper company is vocally or
financially supporting abortion not only
does it make in my mind in my worldview
zero moral sense it also makes zero
economic sense and regardless of how you
feel on the specific issue conservative
people have 41% more kids than
progressives do on average and on top of
that all of Middle America are the ones
having kids on mass the Catholic
communities having kids on Mass these
are largely pro-life communities so my
wife and I we have that conviction and
we thought okay well there's a hole here
in the market there are no pro-life pro-
family pro- Freedom diaper companies and
uh a lot of people in our Market are
really looking for them and they're not
finding them so what do we do we started
a diaper company and we're now the
fastest growing diaper company the
country's ever seen we launched every
life this
summer you can find out more at every
life.com never in a million years did I
think I would have started a diaper
company but you didn't know there was a
need for
that's what's so fascinating about
Public Square functioning this way that
you can say oh I need a product it's not
on Public Square I should make that
product or I should find someone to do
that exactly well and that's part of it
too when we can find a small business
owner that actually has that product
obviously the goal is let's get them on
Public Square but then how can we help
them grow so is it finding them that
access to capital for example there's a
great shoe company called John kandor on
the platform that's competing against
Cole hun they make their shoes
hardworking veterans they are uh leather
that they Source from like Texas ranches
some crazy story that they have but
what's interesting is that they just run
out of inventory kind of often because
they don't have the access to grow like
a Cole Han would and so what we've been
able to do is help Source them partners
that can help their business continue to
expand and grow it's really really cool
I have a great pair of John kers are an
awesome shoe so that's exactly right
where there's a hole we look to fill it
either by creating the business ourself
which we're going to do more of in the
near future or helping the ones that can
fill that need at greater scale continue
to grow it's very ex how many businesses
are on Public Square right now over
72,000 and do you find they are self-
selecting to be on Public Square or are
you having to recruit people out of the
Shadows uh they are definitely self-
selecting praise God we do not have to
seek the businesses too hard what's
fascinating though is in the early days
we had to try really hard in fact when
we launched in San Diego County the
first ever time that was September of
2021 there were 150 businesses on the
platform and each one of those
businesses we had to literally and knock
on their door we asked them like hey you
know a are you forcing vaccines or masks
right now like we really hope not okay
great you're not like can we talk about
what it looks like to join this platform
and showcase your products and services
to this great group of Patriots that
would love to support you we launched
with 150 then the 150 told 150 then they
told 500 then they told a th000 then
they told 5,000 now today you know we
probably had 4 or 500 businesses sign up
today alone and I have no idea how they
heard about us so it's pretty cool
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net